cette norme
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
à grands pas
à 30 ans ophélie labour est supplanté
dans la hideur et la disgrâce l'écu
dessine ses fans les plus tourmentés
elle était intensément l'aide de visages
et de corps et le plus naturellement du
monde c'est à dire sans que jamais le
moindre camions ne lui tend boutigny
qu'un seul virus à séquelles déformante
ni creuse à jamais ses ravages elles
étaient vilaines par la grâce de dieu
marqué à vie au saut de l'utérus
jaillissant de sa tête en poire clouté
de de globules aux paupières à peine
ouvrables elles imposaient un pif
grumeleux patatoïde et rouge vomi qu un
duvet noir de l'essence ingrat séparé
d'une fente à précisent qu'ils pouvaient
faire illusion et passer pour une bouche
au moment de clapoter
autour de ce masque immettables elle
entretenait tout une chimio mry de poils
à balai de crin qui se hérissaient sur
les tempes au temps chaud pour cacher en
vain les pavillons de détresse de ses
oreilles boursouflé dont seule la
couleur identique à celle d'une ai
apporté un semblant d'harmonie au
demeurant regrettable à cette info
remiser
le corps était à l'avenant si l'on peut
dire
cours et trapu sottement cylindrique
sans enjeu ni taille ni sain ni fès une
histoire raté sans aucun rebondissement
2e trop morne s'étirait quatre branches
maigrelette précocément par cheminées et
flasque endeuillé par endroits d'un
pelage incertain les membres inférieurs
plus particulièrement insultes elles
regard
n'était ce leur position dans l'espace
l'une au dessus de l'autre rien ne
permettait de discerner la jambe de la
cuisse l'une et l'autre affûté dans le
même moule à baton s'articulait au
milieu par la protubérance insolite d'un
galet rotulien trop saillants un très un
point un trait
c'était des jambes de maurs
moins affriolantes que bien des
prothèses avec pour seul point commun
avec les jambes des femmes une certaine
aptitude à la marche à pied
la providence dans un de ces élans
sournois de sa méchanceté gratuite qui
l'incitent à faire éclore les plus
belles roses sur les plus écoeurants
fumier avait cru bon d garer au milieu
de toute cette bassesse une perle rare
d'une éclatante beauté ophélie labour
est avait une voix magnifique
déjà quand elle parle elle s'en évader
des sons surprenants velouté dans l'aigu
claquant dans les graves une voix qui
porte et loin sans qu'elle eut jamais à
la poussée et qui m'aiment assourdi pour
les confidences écrasait superbement
alentours les plus négociées caquetages
réduisant les plus ample tonitruance
viril en braiment aphone
quand elle chantait le rossignol confus
s'éteignait son chant brisait les autres
champs près de lui les choeurs de basse
devenait aboiements polyphonique et les
voix cristallines filet de vinaigre
si ophélie labour est était né prescott
ou aveugles un jury particulièrement
doué de mansuétude aurait pu accorder à
dieu des circonstances atténuantes que
lui-même dans l'arrogance égocentrisme
de son infinie sagesse refusa naguère au
docteur frankenstein
mais dieu est un [ __ ] finio l'heure
dans le sadisme comme peu de bourreau
des camps il avait imaginé de doter sa
créature d'une âme d'artiste sensible et
raffiné que soutenait un esprit vif et
brillant enfin content de lui comme un
grand chef pâtissier au moment de poser
l'ultime cerise rouge au sommet de la
pièce montée dieu avait mis au coeur de
felhi labour est une petite perle
brillante et noir indestructible
irradiance enfin de ce corps grotesque
c'était la douleur exquise et pointue du
l'inextinguible jalousie bref et pour
tout dire cette immondice sur pattes
comme peu de peau est sensible à la
beauté des choses et l'harmonie des
formes se mourait de haine pour tout ce
qu'elle aimait et vivait dans l'espoir
excécrable pourrissement des anges
un jour de rouge automne alors qu'elle
cachait ses détresses ou fond d'une
forêt noire ophélie labour est rencontra
dans un sentier caillouteux un gros
crapaud dégueulasse qui coassent et par
là
vous semblez bien triste mademoiselle
dit le crapaud
c'est que je suis épouvantable monsieur
crapaud je donnerai tout au monde pour
quitter ce corps contrefaits et 7 est
repoussante et me changer de peau
je puis quelque chose pour vous dit
encore le crapaud figurez vous
mademoiselle que je suis une fille
ravissante victime du mauvais sort sur
moi je t'ai par la fée la duras
seul un baiser sur mon dos pustuleux
pourra me rendre mon apparence première
si vous me donnez ce baiser mademoiselle
jets d'eau serait votre voeu
aguerris à tous les équipements qu'elle
se voyait dans la glace les jours
ophélie labour est n'hésita pas un
instant elle porta le crapaud à sa
bouche et lui baisa le dos
aussitôt le batracien ce fif est superbe
avec des traits diaphane des grâces de
ballerines et une baguette étoilés dont
elle touche à l'épaule de felhi labour
est en dix ans
abracadabra j'ordonne que cette femme
quitte ce corps contrefaits et 7 est
repoussante et qu'elle change de peau
c'est ainsi qu ophélie labour est se
retrouva d'un coup métamorphosés au
crapo
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour capter mais ils font rien
qu'à mûrir dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
fait peu non